we don't know why that why there's such
an attack on the oil and gas industry
from this administration because what's
their alternative is to buy oil from
russia or saudi arabia because demand is
the same
and and here's something that i'd like
to point out to people every president
of the united states since 1973
has had an energy independence policy
whether they republican or democrat
until this administration and they
wanted to just cancel everything cancel
the keystone pipeline make drilling
impossible
but they they
what they forget is we still have to
drive to work we have to heat our homes
our businesses we have to drive our kids
to soccer practice and football practice
and so the demand is the same and
they're not just they're not being
honest
before we jump into some of the
specifics what else do people have to
know about oklahoma i feel like it's
just like one of those states that
people kind of they go through it they
maybe fly over it and and they don't
think about it that much but you guys
are doing an awful lot when it comes to
energy and a whole bunch more yeah well
i mean i was just uh in in farnborough
england representing our state for the
aerospace and defense industry and some
of the things that that i like to remind
people is we're the 28th largest state
population 19th largest land area-wise
we've got some of the cleanest water
cleanest air in the country we have an
all-of-the-above approach and energy in
other words we love oil and gas
we're number six in oil production
number four natural gas but we're also
number two in wind energy production uh
so we have we're one of only four states
four states that 40 of our energy comes
from renewables and so it's very
attractive to a lot of companies right
now
but we have the largest maintenance and
repair facility on aviation in the
country with tinker air force base so
great aviation industry
we've got an inland port so most people
don't realize that about oklahoma we
have the farthest frost free port in the
country all the way almost to tulsa
so a lot of great things going we got
great agriculture
we feed the world in a lot of cases from
our from our agricultural side number
two beef producer in the country
so a lot of great things going and then
the freedoms uh
oklahoma city i think is the 25th
largest city in the country we've got
the thunder a professional sports team
so the quality of life the commute in
oklahoma is like 15 minutes compared to
an hour in some of the other major metro
areas so people love the quality of life
you've got to come visit oklahoma
and i'm guessing house prices a little
bit better than here in florida right
now
definitely definitely right i mean we
obviously are you know everything's
going up all over the country but our
we've got an arbitrage right now and
that's what businesses are seeing
is that they can come in and the quality
of life with the cost of living allows
them uh to pay less than you can on some
of the coast and uh and with covet
you're seeing people move and say and i
don't have to work in in this big city
or through technology we can live
anywhere uh but we're also seeing
headquarters move to dallas fort worth
and move to oklahoma city and move to
other states and get out of the the new
york city areas or the bay areas where
crime is is rampant and homelessness and
all the stuff that uh doesn't happen in
in our state
you mentioned the amount of oil and gas
you guys produce and then also wind
power does that cause any tension in the
business community or any tension with
the federal government because they the
federal government at least seems to
view oil and gas versus wind as very
very different things they like one they
don't like the other
you know that's the thing that blows
their mind whenever i go and meet with
the bide administration and their
secretary of energy and we talk about it
all the time those things can coexist
together we believe in the free market
in oklahoma we believe in an
all-of-the-above approach
so they do coexist just fine
we love our oil and gas industry and you
can't have an intellectually honest
conversation about the needs of
americans
and a reliable energy grid without
talking about natural gas and talking
about oil
but we don't shy away we're leaning into
hydrogen for example i signed an mou
with with the governor of arkansas and
louisiana we believe that we will get
one of the four hydrogen hubs uh to
prove out it's a two billion dollar kind
of program to prove out of
commercialization use of hydrogen
but you're going to need pipelines for
hydrogen development
we can coexist together and you can talk
about transition and you can talk about
oil and gas and again i we don't know
why that why there's such an attack on
the oil and gas industry from this
administration because what's their
alternative is to buy oil from russia or
saudi arabia because demand is the same
and and here's something that i'd like
to point out to people every president
of the united states since 1973
has had an energy independence policy
whether they republican or democrat
until this administration and they
wanted to just cancel everything cancel
the keystone pipeline
make drilling impossible
but they they
what they forget is we still have to
drive to work we have to heat our homes
our businesses we have to drive our kids
to soccer practice and football practice
and so the demand is the same and
they're not just they're not being
honest
do you think they yeah well that i think
is the part that do you think that they
actually are just simply not being
honest or this is by design that they
they know people have to go to work they
know people have to you know get in the
car but they are sort of telling us hey
we want off this stuff regardless of the
repercussions you know i hope that's not
the case uh but i've seen the reports
just like you that that they make these
statements like well we knew that prices
were going to be jacked up for a while
but
that's going to be part of the process
to get off of oil and gas
and i hope that's not true
because to harm oklahomans or to harm
americans
just because you have some kind of
left-wing agenda
that's not the president that i would
hope would be representing our country
but but you know i i don't know what's
happening because it doesn't make common
sense to most americans on why they are
burying their head in the sand and and
not having an honest conversation when
just a couple years ago we were energy
independent and you're now seeing
inflation skyrocket everything cost more
40-year highs at everything and actually
they harm they're harming the people
that they actually think that they're
protecting that's what people need to
understand is these policies from the
democratic party uh actually hurt
average oklahoma middle income people
the rich get richer and it hurts
everyday oklahomans it's the republicans
it's a free market it's it's
the innovation of business that actually
helps the middle class grow
yeah
absolutely you're preaching to the choir
over here
my audience gets it uh anything else we
should know broadly about oklahoma
before i want to dive into some of this
stuff that i heard you talking about
about what's going on with the native
american reservations there which is
really fascinating but anything else you
want to get off your chest quick yeah no
i'm good i'm good we'll probably i'll
probably be circling back to it
okay so uh when i heard you speak a
couple weeks ago you told a really
fascinating story
and was describing some of the tension
that oklahoma faces over what's going on
with the native american reservations
there and how there is seemingly a
disparate uh
distance in the way laws are being
applied when it comes to native american
population uh versus the average
oklahoman you told a couple anecdotes
about that can you just kind of give me
the 101 on that yeah absolutely well
first off the mcgirt decision came out
in july of 2020 and basically what it
said it was the u.s supreme court
decision called mcgirt so i'll encourage
everybody to look it up but basically it
said
that we still had reservations in
oklahoma so
about half of our state was all of a
sudden turned back into an indian
reservation tulsa oklahoma with a
million people was now considered an
indian reservation and here's the deal
i'm not against the indians i'm actually
a member of the cherokee we're proud of
right you're literally you yourself
literally i can show you my card my
heritage i have indian blood so i have a
membership to the indian uh to the
cherokee nation so it's not an
anti-indian thing but this is a
pro-oklahoma thing this is a common
sense thing so what was happening is we
had tribal governments then saying that
they didn't have to follow the laws of
the state of oklahoma they were saying
that nope that if you were indian you
didn't have to pay taxes in oklahoma but
every other race did
they were saying that the district
attorneys couldn't prosecute crimes the
same way so you had a situation
that you didn't have fairness you didn't
have equal protection under the law if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell